Okay, so starting off this morning, uh
the indexes kind of sideways right now
don't really have that enticing of price
action. The S&P 500 and the NASDAQ are
kind of just in a sideways
slop. We could totally move up here and
find a bounce off this level, but the
problem is just the movement is just
it's just been really tricky to trade
the indexes lately. Uh the markets just
in general have been kind of
really difficult to be honest. Um so but
the exciting ones today I would say are
gold. Yesterday I was watching for this
but you know it looks like it might be
happening today instead. We had this big
downtrend that has started to slow here.
Um, and it's made a spike lower, kind of
bounced. It still hasn't made a higher
high, but what I'm looking at is we
might make one more push lower that
fails and then starts a larger uptrend.
Um, and if we go to 5m minute of gold,
it's definitely got a nice spike down,
which is a nice
potential to have a good kind of snap
back that I like. Um, similar in gold. I
mean, oil here, uh, big, super big
picture. It had a crazy sell off over
here that we just been slowly kind of
working up. Uh if actually if we go to
the 50% level,
it's pretty much at the 50% pullback
level, which would be pretty um crazy
for a reversal level, but just the way
it's acting right now is it's also had
um overnight it had a this is the close
or actually this is kind of midday
yesterday in the market, but it slapped
up sideways,
attempted to go higher again, kind of
failed. Um,
so this is a pretty big good bullish
pullback, but
I could also see it pop up here and fail
lower if it kind of wants to
reverse this move up. Um, yesterday was
kind of like that too of having kind of
some moves up where it looked like it
kind of like same thing right here where
it moved up, pulled back. It looks like
it was going to keep going, but it uh I
looked for kind of a short here, but
didn't get in and it kind of just
petered up higher. So, we'll see. Oil
might just be really bullish. Oil also
has uh oil inventories at about this
time. So, that can sometimes
cause some movement or entries.
And then the markets today have FOMC
um
minutes and we also have news 30 minutes
after the open which is 8:00 my time. So
might get a little bit of movement this
morning but then it could just hunker
down and kind of just sit there uh and
do nothing. The NASDAQ already has had
kind of a spike and whip in the opening
five minutes. Uh, and
we have the news here at at 8,
but I think at the moment it'll just be
kind of wait and I think the more better
opportunities are golden oil.
So, oil looks like it's starting to
maybe do a top here. It's kind of done a
on it's on a one minute chart though and
I really don't want to short based on
one minute chart especially because
I honestly feel overall this is more
bullish. I think it's likely to maybe do
a fake here and then punch higher. So I
would rather
because also this was a nice move up but
like this is pretty healthy into this
area and so there's no reason other than
being here at the previous high that
it's going to fail. It's not really
overextended to the upside in this
recent movement versus like this here
like it's overextended and so as soon as
it kind of slows down it fails quickly.
Um, and so honestly, I would prefer to
pop up here one more time or
clearly break this, pop up, fail, and
then I get in short somewhere here.
But I I don't want to. It just with the
way the market's feeling, this could be
a serious it could just fail. But like
it just it's way more likely to bait.
And if I miss a trade,
that's okay.
I'd rather be more cautious in the
current market conditions.
Gold is still kind of
looking similar in terms of just kind of
hasn't really broken the downtrend yet,
but it's getting there, I would say.
So, gold here has broken this trend. I'd
like to see it kind of do
some kind of double bottom though before
going higher just because it seems like
it's pretty sluggish now. So, I don't
think it's going to snap up right away.
I think that's likely a good way to get
baited in especially with how this
market is. Oil here has broken the
uptrend and made some bearish candles,
but it's just
if you just kind of look at it, it's
just come up here and just started to go
sideways. And especially with news
coming here in 15 minutes, it's very
likely to just chop into the news, which
is it often does that. And
so it'll it'll start moving there once
that we see that. But until then, I'm
going to stay out of it.
I would like to see how the candlestick
after this,
at least for the first minute, reacts.
see if we get kind of a pull down.
But I want to get long here, especially
because the
if it does kind of even just kid back a
little bit. My one thought is gold is
it's not going to be quick. It'll more
likely be like this. So, it could take a
while, which would be kind of a
bummer essentially.
Look at this on a one minute. It's
essentially had
a move up and a little pullback.
It's basically bottomed here with
basically like a head and shoulders.
So, I think I like getting long here.
Again, I'm doing smaller size.
Uh, I think if we do get going,
I mean, my initial target is going to be
this, but depending on how it how it
performs
and if I can just move my stop up and
protect things. I mean, I'll try and
just capture more of the swing.
So, 2x is my initial target, but I think
it's also
there's good potential for
more
So, I think there's good riskreward
potential because it's
I think able to get in pretty close to
the lows on this one.
Part of me thinks maybe I should wait a
little longer, but I think I'm just
nervous because
trading has been difficult lately and
things
have been really just Not great.
Um, on a 15minute,
it's one minute away from closing. I
mean, it's kind of a higher low on a
15minute basically, which is pretty
nice.
But it's,
you know, either way, it's a it's a nice
double bottom
after a trend break. Big picture again,
I am looking for it to bounce here. It's
broken these two. All right. Camera's
covering it, but it's come up and hit
these two spots. We're at this larger
picture.
So, just got to be patient and let it do
its thing.
Well, I'm out
on Gold.
Gold's been really tricky and also just
longs in general have been really really
rough. Um, oil here kind of has made a
nice lower and a push higher. Um, my
thought is it could it's still
definitely in a potential spot for a
failure and lower, but again,
I think I'm probably just going to avoid
it because it's just been choppy. I
think with how the market's been, it's I
need to be
more narrowed and focused in on
really really clean spots. Um, just
because
things are just pretty rough at the
moment for this month. So, after a
little bit of a breather, I've just come
back to the charts and wanting to kind
of re-evaluate how I'm trading going
forwards in this market environment. the
market environment is coming to these
zones and not reversing. A lot of my
trades recently is where it just
continues lower. You know, there are
opportunities, but they're just not very
good. You know, this other trade in oil
today where it comes up, it looks like
it has potential and it just continues
higher. And so, my strategy is all
reversals, right? And so, that's not
very good for my strategy. There's
definitely opportunities, but they're
just not as often. And so I think I what
I want to do going forwards is still
trade. I'm trading half size a lot
because I was already kind of wary of
the market. But I think even more it's
taking just a couple trades a week of
waiting for those really prime spots to
take a trade so that I'm not damaging my
P&L as much and I'm able to still trade
profitably in a horrible trading
environment for my current strategy.
Really, every strategy is going to have
times where the market just sucks for
it. And so you have to learn to
recognize that and adjust going forwards
so you don't blow up your account when
you hit times when the market is bad for
your strategy. Hopefully the market
adjusts soon and I'm going to still stay
it engaged because you don't know. It
could change next week. But until I've
seen the market start to reverse more
cleanly, I'll be more cautious with my
trades.